as the Miami Dolphins try to transform
their roster they are transforming the
organization now Chris Greer the one God
has survived from 2018 he's in charge of
the football operation he's hired head
coach Brian Flores and now Greer has
brought to the front office Reggie
McKenzie the former Raiders general
manager the executive of the year in
2016 and a guy who will go a long way
toward helping the Dolphins find the
kind of talented players that they need
to be as good as they hope to be and
even though John Gruden's first order of
business was to trade Khalil Mack and
then he traded Amari Cooper and who
knows what he's gonna do with
quarterback Derek Carr these are three
guys that Reggie McKenzie drafted in
Oakland he knows what he's doing he
dates back to that that magical time in
Green Bay when they were having great
drafts and great teams and he's got a
lot of contacts he's got a lot of
knowledge he's got a lot of experience
and now he's gonna have an opportunity
to help turn the Dolphins into something
they haven't been for a very very long
time yes they have a couple of Super
Bowl trophies in the case but it's been
well over 40 years since they won one
it's been over 30 years since they've
been in one and now the Dolphins as the
Patriots inevitably won't be as good as
they've been we think there's an opening
there for the Dolphins and with McKenzie
the Dolphins may be moving toward
building the kind of roster necessary to
compete for playoff appearances and
maybe eventually a berth in the Super
Bowl
[Music]
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports